it's one of the most sophisticated
smuggling routes yet
10 meters beneath the u.s mexican border
at tijuana
customs agents have unearthed a super
tunnel boasting hydraulic doors
and even a rail track the tunnel snakes
its way 536 meters under the border and
then
surfaces in a warehouse law enforcement
says
it was the work of professionals is the
fifth
super tunnel that we've intercepted
since 2010
and this tunnel like those that we found
in november of 2011
were built by engineers and architects
the tunnel is estimated to have cost
tens of millions but u.s
law enforcement swooped just after it
opened denying its masterminds any
reward
we have the border underground fairly
well monitored here if they're building
a tunnel
we know about it this is the third one
since 2011.
we found them all before they could
successfully get any drugs into the
united states
u.s customs seized eight tons of
marijuana
and around 150 kilos of cocaine in the
tunnel
officials said they also made several
arrests